[Musique]
dans cette campagne il y aussi ceux qui
ne sont pas candidats pour l'instant
edouard philippe lance son nouveau parti
horizon alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que vous le dire
très personnellement les chapelles les
partis qui se multiplient ça contribue
pas la clarté je veux avec vous
construire un mouvement
construire un parti politique
participé à la constitution d'une
nouvelle offre politique pour que notre
pays que nous aimons puisse regarder
loin si edouard philippe lui même dit
que la réduction des manies de macron
n'est pas acquise c'est qu'il doit avoir
quelques raisons de de le penser l'ordre
moral vient de là il vient de la gauche
le respect qui est devenue une
guillotine à paroles l'idéologie guide
qui serait ce train le leu leu leu les
libertés qui qui qui diminue tout ça
sous prétexte de du bien stéphane le
foll vous dit que vous avez refusé le
débat qui dit que vous n'êtes pas
socialiste vous dit pas assez que vous
n'avez pas de programme il va il va
falloir quand même oui écouter voilà je
sais qu'il ya parfois beaucoup
d'outrance beaucoup de choses qui sont
dites et mais moi je suis pour le
rassemblement c'est un peu dommage de
parler vous que vous vous parlez de la
gauche comme ses mots en parlerait c'est
un peu dommage quand même nom mais si
zemmour et la cce excusez moi c'est pas
un hasard si voilà disais tout ce que
j'en pense tout bas enfin tout ça c'est
une vieille histoire qu'on redécouvre
chauffe avec un personnage nouveau qui
s'est fait passer pour un intellectuel
en plus qu'à trouver le moyen en tant
qu'intellectuel je laisse chacun
réfléchir dette à la fois gaulliste et
pétainiste il dit c'est pour çà de là le
iie dit tout ce qu'on ne dit plus nous
c'est à dire que nous on s'autocensure
nous voyons arriver fort de
télévangéliste comme monsieur zemmour
dont finalement le seul programme sur le
résume c'est les arabes à la mer
derrière la vitre brisée de la devanture
du théâtre du point virgule la fiche de
l'humoriste gaëtan mathis a disparu 24
heures auparavant le comédien provoqué
un tollé sur les réseaux sociaux où les
internautes se sont offusqués de cette
plaisanterie si j'avais une machine à
voyager dans le temps je bous créé le
bataclan pour la soirée du 13 novembre
2015 afin d'y organiser une soirée
rencontre entre eric zemmour et son
public marion maréchal a estimé que deux
candidatures à l'extrême droite diviser
les voix et que le moment venu il
faudrait choisir le meilleur candidat
allusion à eric zemmour actuellement
mieux placé que marine le pen dans
certains sondages c'est un ami de
yassine belattar je crois ce ce grand
démocrate ce grand oléron vous savez
tout ça c'est la même engeance c'est des
gens qui ne supportent pas que les
français veulent rester français si
monsieur zemmour qui n'a absolument
aucune aptitude pour exercer des
fonctions aussi difficile président de
la république pourquoi pas ma part ce
pays n'a jamais dirigé personne de sa
vie il n'a jamais été élu ilna il n'a
même pas monté une seule entreprise
qu'at-il fait de sa vie à part j'allais
dire parler sur les plateaux ce jeu
c'est très bien je ne suis pas inquiète
par conviction et pas inquiète par
expérience précisément parce que vous
rappeler que l'élection présidentielle a
lieu dans six mois dans marge du
rassemblement plusieurs dizaines de
personnes se sont réunis spontanément ou
à l'appel de syndicats pour protester
contre sa venue à certains endroits des
échauffourées éclatent
[Musique]
un camion de la cgt est venu avec une
sono pour parasiter sa prise de parole
diffusant des messages le qualifiant de
raciste de xénophobe de fasciste il ya
des gens qui ont une conception de la
démocratie particulière chez moi la
démocratie c'est la liberté de pensée et
d'expression
chez eux c'est la censure chacun jugera
en france comme en europe des voix que
l'on croyait étouffé ressorte des
tréfonds de l'histoire pour appeler au
rétablissement de la peine capitale donc
vous saturez en réalité l'intégralité
des chaînes d'information continue est
le phénomène zemmour et bien les
problèmes des français ils passent à la
trappe